the jurogan experience but has there
been anything in your life that was so
horrific that they couldn't
imagine telling you
you know except for my father's murder
not really maybe that was it
maybe that was it but
boy that and that doesn't seem like it's
big enough i don't know how was your
father murdered
um
dad
dad was murdered in may of 1999.
had answered a personals ad
for a a woman who was looking for a you
know a boyfriend
and uh
the ad was headlined kismet i believe
that's the arab word for fate
and dad
uh
met with her her name was rita she was a
lawyer
she had worked in the prison system in
the midwest
and dad was really really taken with her
she was really bright and really smart
and she had an ex-husband
who had
sexually abused
her daughter from a different marriage
and they were pressing charges against
his ex-husband and he was going to go to
prison
and she had met him while he was in
prison and she was doing legal work and
she had helped him get out of prison
so she helped him get out of prison
she'd married him he had abused her
daughter
she divorced him
she was prosecuting him to send him back
to prison
then she met my father
and
this ex-husband
had said that if he ever caught her with
another man he would kill them both so
my father
was going to pick her up and she was
going to stay at his house in the
mountains
until the time of the trial
and as he was going to pick her up
he was going down this this mountain
road on his property
and a giant boulder broke free and it
rolled down the hillside and it blocked
the road he couldn't get out
so he spent the day with this
a lever
forcing this boulder off the road
and then he took a couple extra hours
and he made a sign that said kismet rock
so that he could label this boulder as a
kind of landmark but when he brought her
back to sequester her
and he'd cleaned the house incredibly
the house was just neat as a pen and
stocked with all this food and
you know he really planned to have this
fantastically sort of idyllic time
sequestered with his new girlfriend
and he labeled the rock to surprise her
and then he went to pick her up
and when he went to pick her up the
ex-husband showed up
and he shot my father and
my father
and the woman
took refuge in her house
and the man set fire to the house
and the house eventually collapsed
and the coroner says that they were both
dead before the fire got to them
uh
and the coroner says that because of the
angle of the shot my father probably
took about 20 minutes to die because the
bullet ruptured his diaphragm
so with every breath he would have been
accumulating air below between the lung
and the diaphragm and so every breath
would have been more and more shallow
because his lungs would have been more
and more constricted by this air
above the diaphragm
but that eventually he'd suffocated
um
and all of this sounds
horrible and tragic
but
it forms his fantastic pattern in my
father's life because my father
when he was very small
he lived in northern idaho with his this
enormous ukrainian family
and his father
went
uh
crazy one day this is all public record
i've talked about this a lot
but his father took a rifle and walked
around the house
and
tried to kill
him my father and and ultimately killed
my father's well
killed his wife my father's mother
and then killed himself
but my father's earliest memories are of
hiding underneath a bed
as his father walked around the house in
logging boots with a rifle
calling his name
trying to get him to come out so that he
could be killed jesus christ
and so my father spent his entire life
sort of looking
for his mother because as
his father was trying to kill him he was
trying to find his mother who at that
point had been killed
and so my father really had this kind of
serial
pattern with women he was always looking
in a way for the woman the woman
and ultimately he was shot by the man
with a gun
in the way that he would have been shot
when he was four years old
and one of the uncanny things is that
their bodies were only preserved because
a bed on the second floor of this
structure as it was burning the bed fell
over their bodies
and insulated their bodies
and my father had
escaped his father by hiding under
underneath a bed when he was a small
child
and the fact that the the the
lonely hearts ad was was headlined
kismet
and the fact that this boulder rolled
down in front of my father's car just as
he was leaving
that prevented him from getting there in
time where he probably would have been
able to escape before the ex-boyfriend
arrived
or was i you know there's so many odd
bizarre coincidences
and synchronicities you know you could
sort of you would have to really
um
dismiss a lot of things in order to make
this
not something uh significant
not fate or not some
reoccurring theme woven into time
and in a way that you know understanding
all these different aspects of it
it provides a comfort
that it doesn't seem like this random
thing it seems like
something that my father's
some aspect of my father's life that was
coming full circle
and was finally being completed
and maybe i am clutching at straws and
i'm just a kind of person looking for
significance
which is what we all are
but i'll take comfort where i can find
it watch the entire episode for free
only on spotify